often what's bandied about is the idea
that life has a metabolism okay it it it
uses energy it needs a source of energy
so that it can use the energy and then
when it uses the energy it has to
continue to replenish the source and
life needs a way to reproduce itself
otherwise it wouldn't sustain I guess
something can be alive but not ever
reproduce itself but in the full
understanding of what life means and
does on Earth
it has a metabolism and can reproduce
itself okay
if you look carefully at stars
they have a metabolism
they're born they live out their lives
they die and they reproduce themselves
so by some definitions even many
definitions of life
stars are alive
just putting it out there